- All right, let's wrap up this
hour with something awesome
I found scrolling through social media.
This is what I'm liking.
(audience cheering and applauding)
All hour we have celebrated
the value of a good book.
Sadly, this country is seeing
the largest attack on books
in decades with more than
1,500 targeted for bans
in schools and libraries
just last last year.
A Texas woman is fighting that
trend in a really cool way,
opening a bookstore that focuses
on diversity and inclusion.
And she also hosts a giant book club
featuring banned and challenged
books 'cause she's cool.
We have her on the line right now
watching on KEYE TV in Austin.
From Black Pearl Books,
everybody say hello to Katrina.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Hi, Katrina.
- Hi, Kelly! How are you?
- I love it. I love having you on here.
I love a fellow Texan.
So this has been a lifelong
passion of yours, right?
- Yes, absolutely.
So when my kids were
little, we'd always look
for books on representation,
diversity, inclusion.
We'd talk about what they
were learning in school
and if it seemed like they
were only getting part
of the story, I'd always go to the library
or find books that allow for
the full story to be told.
And so fast forward to 2019,
I started an online bookstore,
and we helped popups and markets
to share those same
books with our community.
And then in June of 2020
when the social justice movement happened,
we had over 10,000 online
orders through our website,
which was just insane.
- Wow.
- And we were operating out
of our home at the time.
And so pallets of books were
being delivered to our house
and like, every square inch was covered
with the exception of our bedroom.
Sales continued, and we had
to make some real decisions
for our family, and so
we stepped out on faith
and my husband left his corporate job
and came on board with me
to run the store full-time.
And then last year we
moved into our storefront,
and next time you're in Austin,
we'd love for you to come visit.
- Oh my gosh. Absolutely.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Absolutely, you put a lot of effort
into counteracting book bans as well.
How did you do that?
- Yes.
So unfortunately Texas leads the country
in the most banned books,
which is very, very sad.
And I'm gonna use one
of your favorite words.
We navigate the bowels of censorship
by starting a book club
called Redacted Reads,
and features books.
We read fiction,
non-fiction, graphic novels,
young adult books, even children's books.
And many of which you'd
actually be surprised
are on a banned book list.
So of course the reasons
that they're banned vary.
But it wouldn't come as a
surprise to you that the majority
of the books on the list have
some form of representation,
be it Black, Indigenous,
Jewish, or LGBTQ+.
To that end, we also started a nonprofit
called Put It In A Book, and
we have multiple initiatives
through that nonprofit that provide books
for hundreds of students
throughout our community.
And the phrase "put it in a book"
comes from a not so great time in history
when Blacks were not
allowed to read or write.
It was illegal, and if found
doing so, they were punished.
So it was said that if
you wanna hide something
from a Black person, put it in a book.
They'll never find it.
- Oh.
- So we are claiming that
phrase, using it for good,
and saying, hey, you gotta find
other places to hide things
because we do read, we do write,
and we do have stories to tell.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Absolutely.
It's so important what you're doing.
Thank you so much, Katrina,
from one Texan to another.
I'm liking your post right now, all right?
(bell rings)
(audience applauding)
- [Katrina] All right!
- And that's not all, ma'am.
Our season-long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like you
so they're gonna be
writing Put It In A Book
a check for $1,000, how's that sound?
(audience cheering and applauding)
- (gasps) Oh, thank you! Thank you!
- Absolutely, thank you so much, Katrina,
for everything you're doing.
Thanks to all our guests this hour,
Rachel McAdams, Judy
Blume, Abby Ryder Fortson,
Christine, and The Heavy.
Y'all have a great day. If
it's not, try and change it.